hi and welcome to Google developers live
my name is pong and with me today is my
colleague Maru hi pond hey Mario
today we're talking about the wallet
objects API specifically we'll be going
over the wallet objects QuickStart
sample we have a number of different
wallet objects our samples and today
we're going to be focusing on the PHP
example the quick starts are designed to
provide sample code to help you
understand the API and to get you and to
help you hit the ground running when you
start integrating the wallet objects API
and the quick starts we show a few
things you show how we have sample code
to help you authorize access to show you
how to insert a wallet objects class to
create a new wallet objects and to save
that wallet object using the saved Walt
API and lastly we also show the web
service API to enable account linking
and sign up from a Google Wallet app you
can find ditional information about
getting the QuickStart up and running on
our developer site developers.google.com
slash commerce slash wallet slash
objects and to show you how they get it
up and running
here's Maru thanks Paul so let's start
going to the documentation like Paul
said if you go to our documentation
developers at google.com slash commerce
slash wallet slash objects you'll find
that we have QuickStart samples and
click on PHP so today we're going to
look at the PHP sample it's pretty it's
the same very similar to our other
samples but we're going to go over the
details on how to run it on using PHP
specifically so the first thing that we
recommend is that you watch the account
setup video that we have it's already on
the documentation so just watch that and
once you have your credentials set up
you'll need to get your service account
email address and also a copy of your
private key that you download when you
create your credentials after you do
that the first thing that we need to do
is download the QuickStart project so to
do that we'll go into github
and that quickstarts are open source and
you can find them you can find them on
our github repository github.com slash
google wallet and look for the PHP one
here wallet objects - quick stir - PHP
so just click on that and from there you
can either download the code as a zip
file or you can clone it so I'm just
gonna copy the URL so I can clone it
locally here in here I have see what I
am I'm going to then clone the code and
this is making a local copy of it and
okay so it's done now I'm gonna go into
the directory where that I just cloned
and the first thing I need to do is down
it's copy my private key that we that we
downloaded and I have a copy of it on
the directory above so p12 copy it in
the same directory so now I have it here
and then let's configure the project to
do that we need to edit the file config
that PHP and we're going to open our
editor here and I'm gonna go into the
quick starts and look for the PHP
conflict that PHP file this file in this
file we need to change a few few of
these parameters the first one is the
service account email address so to get
our service account email address we
need to go into the Google Cloud console
and in here click on the api's and look
for the app that you register where you
got your credentials and look for the
email address that ends with developer
the G service account calm copy that and
just paste it in here this is the right
place here
and then let's look for our issuer ID
our issuer ID can be found on the
merchant dashboard and for that going to
the account management page and copy
your issuer ID and we're gonna paste it
here and the next one that we have is
the private key so the private key if
you have the same name that I have which
is warps private key that p12 you can
leave this assist or if you change the
name just please update that the
application name we have a wallet
objects demo you can change this to any
name this does not have to match
anything any of your credentials or
anything that you created already it's
just for OAuth purposes so we can leave
that as we have it here
the origins is a list of URLs that are
used to allow the safe to wall button to
load on your page on our case we're
going to be running the sample under
localhost 8080 so we have that URL here
but if we need to run it on another you
are like we're gonna be running it also
on the on App Engine then we can just
copy here and PHP that appspot.com
and that way it will so load on that URL
then we have four values here for the
loyalty class ID and object ID and the
same for the offer these values you
don't need to change but since we've
been running the QuickStart to test then
we already have the subjects created on
our account so what we'll do here is
that we'll modify them and you can
modify them after you've created if you
can you want to keep making changes to
it so loyalty class PHP I think I have
probably ten of them so let me put 20
here to make sure that I don't have that
already so I'm gonna be creating we're
gonna be creating a loyalty class PHP 20
and object ID loyalty object PHP 20 so
after we do this then we are ready to
run the QuickStart
so how can you run the QuickStart we
have the QuickStart is we can either run
it using Apache or we can run it using
App Engine so on our local server we're
gonna use Apache to show you how it runs
and then we'll upload it to App Engine
then we can use it on our web service
API so here local the first thing that
you need to do is if you're gonna run it
using Apaches make sure you have a patch
of running Apache installed if you don't
have it then install it on the Mac by
default it's already installed so how
you you make sure that it's there it's
just it's Apache CTL so I have it
running I have it on my computer here
and I'm gonna start my but before we do
that you need to make sure that you that
you have on your Apache config file in
here first we have the port here listen
we have it running on port 8080 which is
here and then we also have a new
directory root for our for our site in
this case here we have wallet objects
QuickStart PHP so you'll need to have
some rewrite rules that you can
copy/paste from our documentation so
don't worry about this just copy/paste
what we have and this will allow some of
the the paths to work also we need to
make sure that we have PHP enabled so
just make sure that you uncomment the
PHP module' here on the config and you
also need to have mod rewrite so you
also need to uncomment the rewrite
module so uncommon those if you don't
have them uncomment it modify your
rewrite rules and then save your file
so I already did all of that and then
you can start Apache so to do that
Apache control start
and I'm gonna run it here using pseudo
and now this is running on port 8080 so
no let's go into my browser and Apache
says that it works and because we run it
we created this as the directory then we
have to run it like this with the wallet
objects QuickStart PHP so now you can
see on ours on our demo we have two
steps we have the first step allows us
to insert a class and the second step
allows us to save the object to our
wallet using the save to wallet button
so as you can see we have two verticals
on the demo we have loyalty and offer
and as we keep adding more verticals to
our the Google Wallet objects API then
we'll be adding more buttons to this
demo so now here if I click on insert
loyalty class what this is going to be
doing is it's going to insert in the
class
loyalty PHP 20 that we that will create
that we defined in the config so I
clicked on it and if I look at the log
no I don't have the log open but let me
look at the classes here there was PHP
20 you can see here
PHP 20 it's been created and now if I
click on save card to wallet this will
save the loyalty object PHP 20 to my
google wallet and I'm logged in already
here if I wasn't logged in of course it
would ask me to log in before so on your
site you will most probably not have an
insert you won't have a loyalty insert
loyalty class or insert offer class
button so these are here only for demo
purposes so you can modify your classes
and play with it and save many multiple
times on the save to wallet button
though if you are going to be using it
on your site then you will have either
of these on your site okay so we did
that the third step of the integration
which
mention at the beginning of the video is
the web service API integration when a
user goes into the Google Wallet up and
they click on explore to look at the
programs that we have available and they
find your program and look and click on
join now or I already have a member and
they want to link their account what
happens is that Google takes the
information from the app from the app
and sends a JSON request to your Google
to your web service API and that is
configured in the merchant dashboard so
if you're going to discoverable and you
click on the discoverable here you'll
see that we have the setup for the
linking and the signup and what we're
doing here is that we're saying that we
want to show first name last name or
that we want to get that you want to get
the first name last name zip code email
and phone from the user on signup so
Google will display those fields in the
app for the user to fill up if they
don't have them filled out and then when
I really click on join those will get
sent to you and a JSON request and then
they get sent to the web service API to
the web service endpoint that we define
here under merchant callback
configuration so you can see here we
have whoops QuickStart PHP that up stop
that appspot.com and we're running our
QuickStart on App Engine so we can test
our web service API integration and then
here it's the port that if we're gonna
be we have to run this over SSL so if
you're running or a different port you
need to modify that and then the web
service path which for our QuickStart is
web service so once we have that you
also have to make sure that your
discoverable is in draft mode and
whenever a discoverable is in draft mode
it's white listing it to all of the
users that you have shared your account
with so you go into account management
and share and in here you'll see the
accounts that have access to this
discoverable
so now that we have that we have it set
up and we can do it we can do a test
from the Google Wallet app and pong is
gonna do a demo for us and how that
works I have the Google Wallet Android
app here and within this Android app I
don't have any loyalty objects safe with
this specific account but I can discover
new loyalty objects I can discover new
loyalty programs with the discoverable
as that Mara was talking about so define
one I'm already in loyalty view I can
simply click either add programs or this
plus button at the top I'll just click
add programs here I can see all of them
all wanti programs that are around me or
that I can sign up for our demo program
is called bacon reset GDL and it's still
in draft and I'm long I'm part of the
whitelist so I can see it so I click
into that and I have the option to
either say that I'm a member and link an
existing loyalty account or to sign up
I'll just click sign up because I don't
have the account information right now
and then when I sign up what's happening
is that it's pulling the information
that's from my Google Wallet account and
then pre-populate in the form I haven't
defined a phone number yet so I'll just
enter that in my five five five and then
I'll select I I accept the Terms and
create the account I have one extra five
and now what's happening is that it's
notifying Google to send that post
request to our web servers handler our
web servers handlers parsing it creating
the wallet object creating the shot and
responding to the server with the shot
and then that in turn gets pushed to my
account to create this wallet object
that you see it's not gonna take a look
and what I have and you'll see my bar
code this represents my user ID and some
additional information with some
colorful text and now to figure out
what's going on or to find out what's
going on behind the scenes
here's Mara to describe how the code
actually works great Thank You pong so
let's look at the code now so first
thing I'm gonna do is open the
before we go over the web service API
let's look at the page the index page
which is where when you run the the
QuickStart on your browser you'll see
the page where we have the buttons to
insert the loyal' the classes and then
also to do the save to wallet buttons so
here you can see that we have two
buttons for the class and then we also
have two divs where we display the save
to wallet buttons and then we're also
including a J's file and the JavaScript
file what it's gonna do is that it's
gonna add options to our buttons and
it's also gonna load the save to wallet
buttons so first we look at here and
let's see so loyalty here the idea of
this button here when you click on it
what we're saying is that when you click
on it call insert type loyalty and then
I'll show you in the code what that's
doing and then on the second line where
we have loyalty save what we're saying
is let's see where's the ID so for
loyalty saved we're calling an ajax call
to job type loyalty and this is gonna
then send back the job with a loyalty
object and display it back to the page
and display the button back to the page
so that's for that index then let's look
at what the job insert and web service
API are doing to do to look at that
first we can see where is the I can't
see okay so here's the insert first
insert PHP is the one that's gonna be
handling the insert Handler so in here
we say if the case loyalty what we're
gonna do is insert we're gonna call the
REST API and call the insert method with
a new loyalty class that we're
generating and the same will happen of
course for the offer class if we do the
jot here
you can see here we have also a type oil
tea in this case we're generating a
loyalty object and we're adding that
object to our to our payload and then
we're creating the here we're creating
the job and we're signing it and then
sending it back
we're just echoing that back to the page
which is how the button gets displayed
on the page and the last thing that we
have is the web service so the web
service PHP here let's see what this is
here okay so in here what we're doing is
that we're getting the request from
Google and we're checking the parameters
so if you look at the documentation
you'll see that the request includes the
wallet user information in this case we
have first name last name all of the
information that we selected on the
merchant dashboard so we have first name
here we're putting it here and then
we're checking that first name and this
is only for testing purposes so we can
send different codes as the first name
and then test different responses on the
app so in this case we're saying if the
first name includes success then we're
gonna return a success otherwise we're
gonna return an error in error code so
if its success we are generating the
loyalty object and we're putting it in
the response and then sending that back
if it's not success then we are
generating we have a web service
response error which can be either
invalid linking ID or account already
linked and this is only for testing
purposes of course this would you would
need to make sure that you're returning
the correct application code and you can
see those in our documentation and if
I'm returning that it's the wrong data
or the wrong format then we can also
return which fields are invalid in this
case we have zip code and phone once we
have that we also create the response
body and the response body is also a job
to get signed and then gets also echoed
back to the response
so this is how a high level of
integration works with a web service API
also in the let's see we have the header
that PHP includes the let me see where
that is and here includes the where we
create the clot the Google client and
we're using the Google client library
for PHP and here we set our account we
were private key and our service account
email address to do the authentication
so this is handling the authentication
getting your credentials and it's also
saving the token in session and then
refreshing and if the token expires so
all of that is that is done using the
the API client library so you don't need
to worry about how that works other than
that just look through the code and and
the ideas that you guys also also the
verticals are really important here if
you look at the verticals loyalty for
instance you see how we're creating the
loyalty class and also the loyalty
object and these are fields that we have
here's test values so the idea is for
you to go and modify some of this and
play with the values and see how that
displays on the app once you start
getting that modified so this is it for
the video today we hope you find this
helpful
and please look at our documentation for
more detailed information on how to set
up the quick starts in our tutorials and
we also have a lot of helpful videos on
our Google developer Channel you can
also go to our Google+ page or find us
on Twitter plus Google Wallet and we'll
see you next time this time